the bite administration's student loan
relief plan has the potential to affect
tens of millions of americans we're
talking about thousands of dollars of
debt per loan
a debt that would otherwise take decades
to repay so this could influence many
people's finances how they're using
their money today also in the future but
what does the decision mean for you that
is the question we're going to put to
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger who joins us now jill good
morning exactly who i want to talk to
about this issue
uh so lots of people never went to
college don't have loans other people
have already paid them off but a lot of
people still have that debt so for those
folks who's eligible and when might they
get relief
okay so there this is only pertaining to
federal student loans that's 1.6
trillion dollars outstanding of the 1.74
trillion of loans so about 90 of student
loan borrowers there are thresholds
based on income so
if you have a federal student loan and
you earn less than 125 000 as an
individual you will actually have 10 000
of that loan wiped out now if you're
married or you file head of household
then your threshold is higher it's 250
000 but there's one more level because
there is a 20 000 debt cancellation for
those borrowers who received pell grants
those were the grants that were geared
towards low income borrowers and one
other thing about this that's really
interesting
parent plus loans through the government
are also eligible and that is also based
on those thresholds
you know i saw one non-profit describe
it as bailing water out of a sinking
boat without plugging the leak this
really doesn't address the high cost of
college for many many people
in-state tuition almost ten thousand
dollars for people at this point
how much is this going to end up costing
taxpayers and those who are eligible how
do they go about trying to get this
money back
so this is a tough question about what
it's going to cost we had one estimate
by the penn wharton budget estimate that
looked at this plan and said it should
cost about
300 billion dollars now that's true it
would cost that but a lot of the money
that people owed would not have been
paid back anyway we would have written
it off as taxpayers over time so we
don't know the real numbers so yes 300
billion massive number in terms of how
you actually are looking at getting this
relief what's interesting is the
government says hey for eight million
borrowers we've got your income
information it will happen automatically
i would not count on that what you need
to do is go to studentaid.gov
debt relief by the way be patient that
site crashed yesterday it was very pokey
this morning you are going to be waiting
for information and you will have to
fill out a form that means about 35
million people who don't have income
information go do it and even if they
have your information do it anyway one
other issue that's really important and
that is for current students current
college students you're eligible as well
but if you're claimed by your parent or
your guardian as a dependent it's their
income threshold which will determine
your eligibility
it's usually dollar dollar deal but it's
keep it real jill today thank you so
much for joining us and keeping us
caught up on everything we need to know
we'll talk to you soon coming